[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bonsoir à tout
c'est une réelle joie pour moi que
d'être ici ce soir est de voir tous vos
visages après autant des changes virtuel
ces derniers mois en effet j'ai réalisé
ce discours aux ingénieurs alors remis
des diplômes à louvain ce discours vous
êtes des adultes vous avez vos diplômes
la vie est à vous alors on écoute et
plus ceux issus de ce monde périmés de
ce constat d'échec que nous vivons ne
l'écouté plus moi n'écoutez plus les
parents n'écoutez plus les profs ne
comptait plus les punis et journaux
écoutez vous écouter vous en tout
premier a peut-être que certains d'entre
vous l'ont déjà vu lever la main pour
voir alors est mince
je vais pas pouvoir refaire le même donc
ce discours était vu aujourd'hui plus de
7 millions de fois dans le monde entier
dans les réseaux sociaux il a beaucoup
circulé dans les écoles et il m'a
apporté en tout cas énormément de
commentaires
ce témoignage qui m'ont ému aux larmes
pendant des jours entiers pour grandi un
peu compte de comment j'ai pu me sentir
après ces jours là imaginez que vous
êtes dans une ville assiégée et vous
êtes seul en plus dans cette ville un
peu comme bandage là dans sa citadelle
entouré de millions d'orques tout moche
et vous êtes agressé par des politiques
antisociales par un changement
climatique par des médias anxiogène que
plus de pub partout depuis pour des gros
4 4 des pubs sexistes des plus qu'un
site à la consommation et aux
gaspillages et on m'appelle pour faire
ce discours à des jeunes met donc j'y
vais j'ai envie vraiment de les
encourager du fond du coeur mais c'est
aussi quelque part une espèce les appels
à l'aide
parce que ce serait quand même pas mal
de me sentir moins seuls dans cette
citadelle
et donc quand je reviens après avoir
fait le discours comme dans les films je
regarde très remarque naître
d'ordinateurs voir si je verrai pas à
l'horizon se découper des silhouettes
d'une relève des renforts imaginez un
peu comme man je me sente de trois jours
plus tard lorsque je vois cette immense
foule se dresser c'est reconnaître et
devenir chacun chacune à leur place un
nouveau bastion contre les agressions
une nouvelle zone d'accueil des possible
parce que maintenant nous savons que
nous formons ce grand groupe informel
savez-vous d'ailleurs qu'elle est la
première mesure que prennent toutes les
dictatures lorsqu'ils arrivent au
pouvoir
c'est l'interdiction des rassemblements
et savez vous pourquoi
c'est évidemment parce qu'ils n'ont pas
du tout envie d'avoir
des gens qui vont scander dans la rue
des choses qui vont ternir leur image
mais c'est surtout ce qui est avancé par
les sociologues et des politologues
c'est surtout parce qu'ils veulent
éviter à tout prix
ces rebelles les contestataires les
subversifs descendre dans la rue se
regardent dans les yeux se reconnaissent
et sage finalement combien ils sont
quelle est leur nombre ce genre de
régime
pour eux c'est extrêmement important
d'avoir d'une part un appareil de médias
de propagande qui va dire toujours tout
va bien que leader jouit d'une
popularité sans faille et aussi d'un
appareil de répression qui va confiné
subversive les contestataires chez eux
au pire en prison pour que ces gens là
se sentent un groupe négligeable et
isolés ils savent pertinemment bien ces
dictateurs que le pouvoir d'un groupe
augmente non seulement avec sa taille
mais avec la conscience que le groupe a
de sa propre taille et maintenant nous
sommes beaucoup à savoir que nous
écoutons cette voix intérieure qui nous
rend sensible il nous met sur un chemin
du bonheur
j'ai eu un moment de témoignage qui se
disait avoir vécu des choses semblables
à ma vie que ce jaillissement de la voix
intérieure après un épisode de la vie
car en effet ma vie n'a rien
d'extraordinaire moi je
je viens d'une famille banale avec mon
père prof une maman qui peignait est
artiste et donc moi depuis tout petit je
dessinais gribouillé je peignais
j'adorais ça j'écrivais aussi des
nouvelles puis des amorces de romans et
mon père en voyant tout sa musique
évidemment je ferai un excellent
ingénieur civil
salaire comiques comme ça mais j'ai
quand même loin d'être le premier qui
fait des études qui ne correspondent pas
franchement juste parce qu'il suit le
conseil des parents et je critique pas
du tout ce conseil des parents ils
arrivent de toute façon à un âge où en
tout cas moi j'étais tétanisée à l'idée
de devoir faire un choix que la société
m'avait fait croire qu'ils seraient pour
toute la vie gravé dans le marbre
un choix irrévocable irréversible alors
qu'à l'époque j'avais plutôt l'habitude
de devoir choisir entre le bus et le
tram pour aller au cinéma et les potes
et puis nos parents ils ont grandi à une
époque où il fallait absolument il y
avait ce mantra là il fallait absolument
contribuer à la société coûte que coûte
contribuer financièrement à sa famille
n'importe quel prix et puis c'est
l'époque où on s'est dit que on allait
utiliser la sacro sainte croissance et
le sacro-saint pib comme les deux
ingrédients d'une potion magique qu'elle
ait tous nous rendre super heureux alors
que maintenant on voit plutôt que c'est
une espèce de soupe indigeste qui nous
rend tous malades
et puis il ya ce ce ted qui m'a
bouleversé bouleversé c'était de ken
robinson un grand pédagogue anglais qui
parlait d'énormément de choses qui m'ont
extrêmement fort touchée évidemment
cette importance de trouver cette cette
activité qui nous emplit de joie et dans
laquelle on peut se plonger des heures
durant sans voir le temps passer
mais il a aussi beaucoup parlé du
système éducatif
ce système où vont nos enfants
aujourd'hui donc qui disait que ça il a
été complètement chamboulée
lors de la révolution industrielle en
angleterre et on a commencé à ce moment
là à se dire qu'on ferait bien des
écoles qui aiderait à faire tourner les
usines
dis donc ils ont mis en parallèle le
système éducatif et le système
industriel et donc c'est à ce moment là
qu'on a fait une hiérarchie dans les
matières les matières les plus
importantes seraient celles qui
contribuerait le plus facilement le plus
efficacement aux usines donc les
sciences
et les matières à l'autre bout du
spectre serait celle dont on sait pas
très bien quoi faire dans cette société
industrielle naissante les arts et donc
il serait dans le cursus habituel soit
optionnel dans le meilleur des cas soit
on attend on en a pas vraiment besoin
donc vous savez maintenant pourquoi mon
père comme énormément d'autres personnes
pensent encore aujourd'hui que les
études d'ingénieurs sont les plus
importantes qui soit et pourquoi il m'a
gentiment invité à faire ses études
comme une carte monopoly qui m'évite
très plein d'ennuis dans la vie et donc
ses études moi je les fais j'y prends
goût en fait j'y prends tellement goût
que finalement j'ai fait en six ans au
lieu de cinq
ce qui en fait me laisse le temps de
d'écouter ma voix est de vraiment faire
c'est à côté à faire ces activités qui
me passionne et donc je deviens critique
de cinéma pour un grand groupe
je réalise un court métrage d'animation
qui me prend 5 ans et je fais des études
de beaux-arts en cours du soir qui me
mèneront à ce que je fais aujourd'hui
quand je fini ses études
j'arrive au monde du travail et là c'est
une vraie claque voyez ça me déstabilise
encore c'est une claque parce que là je
rends dans une grande multinationale
comme beaucoup d'ingénieurs jeu rendant
une grande multinationale et comme
beaucoup d'ingénieurs on me demande de
faire des trucs totalement inintéressant
là non seulement j'ai plus le temps de
consacrer de me consacrer à toutes ces
activités que j'adore qui me passionne
mais en plus nous demande de faire des
choses que ma voix intérieure mon âme me
dis que sont pas vraiment hyper urgents
dont on sait tous aujourd'hui que on est
dans un bateau tout ce qui prend l'eau
et qui est vraiment des trucs dans
lesquelles ce serait bien de s'atteler
il ya
une crise migratoire une crise
climatique il ya des injustices et
concentration de richesses et moi on me
demande de faire des rapports des
rapports en plus sûr voilà des budget de
groupe au sein de la multinationale des
rapports qui vont être passées à mon
supérieur il validera polio fait un
rapport il va passer à 100 super et va
lire le rapport il va passer à son
supérieur aux actionnaires et alors mais
je commence à avoir ses coulisses du
système et en même temps que je vois
c'est ce coulisses du système je me
prends la deuxième claque de ma vie
encore plus existentielles
avec la mort de mon père à 57 ans j'en
avais 29 d'un accident aussi soudain que
tragique et là je vois les coulisses de
notre mortalité
je vois combien notre corps est fragile
et combien chaque seconde des précieuses
et pourquoi finalement notre âme notre
voix intérieure et si navré de voir
s'écouler ces secondes sans qu'elles
aient un sens qui nous parle alors que
en journée moi j'étais dans ces
multinationales et j'avais des collègues
qu'ils avaient sur leurs écrans des
comptes à rebours du nombre de minutes
qui leur restait à prester avant la
retraite c'est véridique et donc là il
ya quelque chose qui a sauté hier
là il ya mon mégaphone mon ma voix
intérieure qui a pris un mégaphone et
qui a commencé à me crier comme ça
l'oreille chaque soir tous les soirs
depuis à mon avis jusqu'à la fin de mes
temps mais mes jours maintenant que tu
sais que tu peux mourir demain aurait pu
changer quelque chose à cette dernière
journée que tu aurais passé et si cet
épisode
le déclencheur l'étincelle pour une mise
sur un chemin vers le bonheur qui
prendra je suppose toute une vie il ya
eu plein d'autres outils car oui
chercher le bonheur ça se travaille
c'est un vrai travail et donc il ya
plein d'autres outils comme la
méditation comme des conférences des
livres des psys j'ai fait aussi une
formation en coaching et puis à huy cet
outil dont j'avais vraiment envie de
vous parler qui a transformé ma vie et
qui me tient vraiment à coeur parce
qu'il est accessible à tous c'est un
groupe de réflexion en effet à ce moment
là mais trente ans lorsque je me posais
ces questions a dit que l'essentiel j'ai
eu la chance d'être entouré d'amis qui
se l'est posée aussi et donc on a décidé
de formaliser sa et de se réunir une
fois par mois pour en discuter
une fois par mois et puis ça a pris plus
de 5 en presque six ans donc ça fait
vraiment beaucoup de soirées beaucoup
d'heures passées à discuter de choses de
questions existentielles personnel
philosophique des questions comme qu'est
ce qui nous rend vraiment heureux
qu'elle ait le les chemins notre vie
qu'est ce qu'on aimerait apporter à la
société et des questions plus systémique
plus globale comme quel est le rôle des
médias dans notre vie quel héros des
pubs quel rôle des banques
quels sont leur influence sur nous et
quelles seraient les leviers
a contrario que nous on pourrait créer
pour nous distancer de cette influence
du coup devenir plus libre et donc au
fur et à mesure que ce groupe
grandissait pendant tous ces six ans on
est passé de 5 à 20 personnes
on se sentait bien dans ce groupe on
s'est serré les coudes en changer
ensemble on sentait moins seul
c'était un peu comme un groupe de
groupes de soutien à des gens qui
essayent de se désaccoutumer du système
comme un groupe de communes zones de
refuge d'accueil de réfugiés du système
ça ne vous
pas vraiment comme statistiques solides
mais en tout cas de toutes ces personnes
avec qui j'ai fait ce groupe
maintenant ça fait dix ans j'en connais
aucune aujourd'hui qu'ils soient passés
par la case burnout et on a tous
aujourd'hui
au contraire des profils que l'on
appelle atypique des profils atypiques
parce que on est tous atypique parce
qu'il nous ressemble parce qu'on est
tous uniques tous autant que nous sommes
et que nous on a décidé de ne plus
regarder ce reflet dans le miroir que la
société nous renvoie ce reflet de ce qui
en fait ce serait le plus utile pour les
usines on a cassé miro on a été voir
derrière qu'elle serait en fait les
vrais portion de nous mêmes que l'on
aimerait prendre avec nous dans notre
quotidien et donc ça donne par exemple
un consultant en traitement d'image qui
est à mi temps aujourd'hui comédien
professionnel
un docteur en sciences appliquées qui
aujourd'hui le coordinateur des villes
en transition de belgique de rob hawkins
un médecin qui a créé un groupe de
méditation pour soigner en pleine
conscience ou moi ingénieur de formation
est aujourd'hui qui vit depuis sept ans
de son art qui est représenté en galerie
dans plusieurs continents et donc
aujourd'hui on en est au point un
nouveau où ce gouvernement ces
gouvernements et leurs bras de médias
nous disent que tout va bien
ou en tout cas tu vas pas bien mac en
tout cas y'a pas d'autres alternatives
qu'on donne les laisser faire et
continuer comme ça et nous autres avec
ses lois qui détricote le social mais
aussi avec nos smartphones aux réseaux
sociaux
on pourrait tenter de se confiner chez
nous
et du coup finalement nous les rêveurs
les bienveillants les subversifs les
rebelles et contestataire on pourrait
croire que nous sommes un groupe
négligeable et isolées alors maintenant
que nous savons que nous sommes dans un
grand groupe informel
tenons les ces réunions ces groupes ces
manifestations ces rassemblements
sortons de notre citadelle allons voir
la citadelle de l'autre du voisin on
connaît tous des gens avec qui on
aimerait refaire le monde et se
construire ensemble protégeons nous les
uns les autres comme les pingouins face
au blizzard qui se tiennent chaud comme
ça et s'alternent en première ligne
protégeons nos rêves construisons les
ensemble protégeons notre sensibilité
notre bienveillance car oui encore
aujourd'hui c'est un acte subversif que
de rester bienveillant envers et contre
tout margaret mid une grande entrepôts
log américaine a dit ne doutez jamais
qu'un petit groupe de gens réfléchis et
engagé puisse changer de monde car c'est
toujours comme ça que cela s'est passé
alors imaginez notre puissance ne serait
ce que sur nos propres vies et notre
avenir
maintenant que nous savons que nous ne
sommes pas un petit groupe
maintenant que nous savons que nous
sommes des millions merci
[Musique]
de mobilité